[Musique]
télévision britain's got talent
mais on y est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je passais pas loin de la mort g une
jambe qui est bousillée mais je suis
encore capable de faire plein de choses
je peux encore et se rassurent le doigt
bien sûr physique un truc toujours mis
sur pied cogic donc j'ai un mélange des
deux c'est sûr bon maintenant on fait
avec
ils sont les corps cassé de la france
des soldats blessés qui ne peuvent plus
combattre
la france a sélectionné ses dix soldats
parmi les plus méritants pour se mesurer
aux autres nations pendant ces jeux un
peu particulier où les participants sont
tous des blessés de guerre
[Applaudissements]
là
les suspentes
quand je vois mon drapeau qui flotte et
une cure authentifie je suis fier ça
fait quand même quelque chose j'avais
j'avais des frissons
ouais ça
pour ça on pense à plein de choses enfin
chacun le vit différemment
parce que sur un instant t on va penser
à si la femme est
vous avez pensé à moi
noah chi
hu a honnêtement il ya eu beaucoup de
choses qui se bousculent et que ce soit
ce soit les collègues ont été blessés
avec moi que ce soit la famille que ce
soit mais les collègues qui sont
sont restés au régime angers concert
j'appelle chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lionel a déjà quatorze ans de service
dans l'armée comme parachutiste
il a été de toutes les opérations
extérieures
immense auteur de la voilà il va faire
trop 10 et 15 minutes de voler à
kapilimai familles vont chauffer
partant de là nous
[Musique]
c'est devenu une promenade presque
obligatoire le dimanche avec sa fille
parce que sauter en parachute le fait
toujours autant rêver même après
l'accident qui a failli lui coûter la
vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
afghanistan mali le parachutiste
aguerris faisait partie des soldats
français engagés sur les terrains de
guerre et pourtant c'est lors d'un
entraînement que sa vie a basculé
[Musique]
j'ai été blessé le 28 septembre 2016 sur
un saut en parachute de nuit donc à 300
mètres en sorte de l'avion là singles se
déroule le parachute s'ouvre la fin une
soixantaine de mètres en torche j'aime
pas qui est très fort
j'ai perdu connaissance quand même temps
je sais pas et je m'aperçois que que ma
jambe mais les palauencs devrait être et
donc là mais mon cerveau prendre
conscience de salade ou leur arrivée
puis à moi je crie je signale que je
suis blessé et puis ensuite on envoie le
message pour les secours
[Musique]
un miracle qu'il soit encore en vie et
de boue après plusieurs mois en fauteuil
roulant et deux opérations aux jambes
alors dire la plus grosse partie de la
blessure physique puisqu'elle a
quelques-unes c'était donc ici puisque
juqu'à de fractures à ce niveau la cage
atterrit donc j'ai eu une plaque une
plaque de ce côté là je me lantourne la
jambe
j'ai une deuxième plaque ici avec 13 10
donc il a fallu remuscler tout le monde
et j'ai pu de merde en totalité à chiens
j'ai plus de sensibilité sur toute cette
partie là de la jambe j'ai quelques
muscles qui reviendront plus dans pareil
il a fallu pallier sa et musclé autour
et ça veut dire quoi concrètement puis
retournés en opération et ça j'en sais
rien enfin j'ai pas vraiment je pense
sur ce coup là le courage il envie de le
savoir
et si sûr que ça sera plus comme un nom
c'est sûr ce serait mise en danger pour
moi pour les autres si c'est pour partir
au combat une des collègues et faire une
évacuation sanitaire parce que au bout
de quelques marches ou de quelques temps
je suis pas bien c'est un c'est pas pro
quo
ça c'était en afghanistan
notamment quand
tu trouves pas talent dans cette tenue
de militaire
bon
c'est vrai ça c'est la vérité sur
toujours la bouche des enfants
j'ai fait pas mal de missions on va dire
que les pertes qu'elle aime le plus
important ça va être l'afghanistan
certains pays d'afrique ça m'a pris
quand même beaucoup on laisse toujours
une part de noms dans les pays après je
suis fier de tout ce que j'ai fait les
gens à qui je les fais c'est grâce à eux
aussi que j'en suis là
certains qui sont plus là d'ailleurs un
d'autres qui sont blessés
comme moi
mais j'en garde un grand sentiment de
fierté j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire
je suis fier d'eux je vais faire mon
métier je faire de ce que je fais
[Musique]
sa femme mélissa a dû s'adapter et se
réhabituer à la présence de son mari il
est désormais tous les jours à la maison
qu'est ce qui va changer dans l'ensemble
depuis sa blessure
[Musique]
mais oui ça fait très mal oui après
enfin de sokal avion via la rockhal yuki
qu'il a pris sous sa jambe ça sa journée
c'est bientôt partie mis sa magie partir
de sa vie
avant il rentrait et c'était tellement
des terrains difficiles ou des voiles à
la fatigue qui s'accumule donc y rentrer
se reposer que maintenant c'est une vie
complètement différentes et qui
connaissait pas voilà en fonction du
planning de jade et de l'école il
prépare les repas et prépare jade il
amène à l'école des choses qui pouvaient
pas faire avant
la blessure n'est pas seulement physique
des flashbacks de son accident parfois
en pleine journée
des cauchemars violent au milieu de ses
ennemis une maladie invisible appeler un
syndrome post traumatique
par crainte ou par pudeur il ne nous en
parlera pas
seuls sa femme et sa psychologue
connaissent son mal profond
c'est au rendez vous chez la psy ça
s'est bien passé on a travaillé un petit
peu encore sur le sur l'hypnose par
rapport au saut aussi voir si on peut
avoir les bonnes peur et par les
mauvaises
ça commence à rentrer dans l'orne est
encore à pas mal de pas mal de séances
là dessus on va faire quelques unes le
reste on travaillera prêts l'an priorise
par rapport à la première cause la
blessure donc
ça devrait aller
[Musique]
à
et comment se manifeste cette rôle
psychologique va démarrer au quart de
tour impulsivité impatients
voilà ça va être des petites colères
comme ça et il faut réussir à les gérer
et à le calmer et puis à discuter c'est
suffit de discuter et de trouver les
bonnes actions à mettre en place après
voilà ça faisait quand même petit moment
depuis plusieurs terrains où je lui
disais d'aller voir aller voir un psy
parce que j'avais vu son caractère qui
avait changé six scénarios pour un c
c'est décembre au feu rouge parce qu'en
nous klaxonnent alors que au travail au
sang-froid exemplaire ça peut arriver
c'est pas une excuse c'est vrai que déjà
rentrer en afghanistan autret m'avait
dit que j'aurais peut-être consulté mais
bon moi je suis d'un naturel toujours à
prendre sur moi essayer de ne charger
idée par lui du sport autres donc je
pensais que j'arriverai à gérer hélas le
fait d'être d'être blessé savare a
décidé à y aller parce que bon après y'a
le couple est ce important les amis il
faut pas en arriver à des solutions
extrêmes à à se pourrir la vie comme on
dit moi je ne serais pas là sans elle je
serais pas
là où je suis en ce moment sans que ce
soit sans être blessé ou en étant blessé
si sûr qu'elle m'a beaucoup aidé m a
beaucoup supportés dans les deux sens du
terme
donc
merci
[Musique]
mélissa la sauver d'une grave dépression
le sport l'aide aussi à remonter la
pente d'ailleurs elle a encouragés à
participer à la compétition aux états
unis
[Musique]
entraînement départ en mission retour au
régime en huit ans comme ça pour
guillaume et puis un jour tout s'est
arrêté
je suis resté un an et huit mois en
arrêt de travail et moi ce qui me
faisait le plus c'était d'avoir
l'impression d'être inutile
pour moi être un soldat c'est dans les
tripes c'est pas parce qu'on enfile un
tri que l'on devient soldats
sinon je mets un costume de super héros
je deviens un super héros c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche
à l'instant t quand on a besoin de nous
on répond présent et c'est tout ce qui
importe
à 31 ans célibataire guillaume a tout
sacrifié pour l'armée
[Musique]
au quotidien j'ai ce qu'on appelle une
orthèse
c'est une lame en carbone en fait qui
est moulé sur ma jambe et elle ne permet
en fait de garder le pied droit et donc
ça ça me permet de marcher bien après il
ya toujours la perte musculaire qui fait
que la marche c'est toujours compliqué
que je fatigue plus vite donc c'est un
bon outil pour la façon de marcher mais
ça remplace pas john quoi
guillaume atouts journal
les couloirs de son régiment affiche
cette histoire son histoire l'opération
barque anomalie avec son détachement il
a fait face aux djihadistes du sahel
je suis j'étais là c'est un briefing
avant départ avant de partir sur un
convoi logistique au mali en 2016 c'est
là le gt en tant que chef de bord deux
patrouilles de circulation routière
c'est arrivé le 26 juin 2016
en début d'après midi à 14 heures
on était en tête de convoi
on a roulé sur un engin explosif
improvisé
on a sauté sur 40 kg d'explosifs
bon j'ai eu un arrachement du grand
fessier et du nerf sciatique
on a évoqué le fait de mon but et est
donc j'ai eu le pronostic vital engagé
pendant un petit moment mais
bon bah je me suis remis bien et vite
un autre parcours du combattant commence
alors à l'hôpital militaire de percy en
banlieue parisienne
une dizaine d'opérations chirurgicales
des mois de rééducation pour être à
nouveau debout et marcher
[Musique]
j'étais en train de dire à ton cobayes
que il avait tiré le bon numéro
j'étais à ta place elle m'a fait
souffrir mais
quand on voit le résultat ça vaut la
peine
l'hôpital est un peu une deuxième maison
pour tous les soldats blessés
notre caméra est la bienvenue mais doit
rester discrète et abuse un peu
d'ailleurs ça change
je suis venu en consultent la mort le 2
octobre
à cela ça va
j'ai repris à un peu plus d'un an
sur un poste administratif connaît
c'est pas fou
c'est pourquoi les rendez vous médicaux
se sont espacées mais la douleur est
toujours là
comment la soulager guillaume est venu
poser la question à son médecin
lui en fasse tout initiale à votre
action oui maintenant à trois ans à peu
près autre accident est survenu au mali
n'avait plus trop
si je pourrais en avoir toujours le
problème c'est que les cachets sont
tellement costaud que le supporter c'est
pas que je ne supporte pas mais quand je
les prend alors toute la longue et non
plus j'ai pas mal mais mais je sais rien
donc moi il faut réussir
à faire la part des choses donc moi je
préfère avoir une vie active et serré
les dents
la gestion d'un soldat blessé est
différente de celle d'un civil elle est
différente barre par le contexte dans
lequel elle survient pour justement il
ya sept
une explosion je pense qu'à bien de
aussi violent sur le plan de à la fois
du ressenti initiale des visions
multiples que ça peut créer
des brûlures que ça d'occasionner
également de
cette sensation de mort imminente est
vraiment plus forte encore il est à
serait cellule a plus de chance encore
peu développée après une explosion
qu'après un accident de la voie publique
par exemple et en termes de résilience
et de
courage face à aux difficultés on
observe vraiment des différences nettes
en général
ils sont beaucoup plus résilient que
je dis pas qu'un personnel civil ne peut
pas l'être mais on a rarement de
difficultés de manque de résilience chez
nos patients militaires on peut en avoir
je n'ai pas sensibles je me souviens
encore de quand je suis monté en
orthopédie et qu'on a opéré la première
fois on a dit bon là
ça va être compliqué il ya du travail à
beaucoup d'opérations j'ai dit bon très
bien quand est ce que je pourrai marcher
et on m'a dit ben
en étant très optimiste peut-être six
mois sinon faut compter plutôt un an
j'ai très bien je prends de six mois et
avant les six mois j'étais debout je
commence à marcher dans les couloirs
mais parce que j'avais vraiment envie de
me remettre sur mes jambes
guillaume a terminé sa rééducation
physique mais il ne retrouvera jamais
l'usagé normal de sa jambe il n'ira plus
en opération militaire
guillaume n'a plus qu'une idée en tête
partir en amérique affronter les autres
blessés
al'approche de leur compétition des dix
soldats participent à une semaine de
stage de cohésion pour devenir une
équipe l'équipe de france des blessés de
guerre
le pire c'est que c'est vraiment trop le
coup c'est ça qu'il fallait
ils vont apprendre à se connaître
c'est parfois difficile de parler de ce
qu'on a eues avec les gens qui sont pas
forcément fait que ce soit les amis la
famille pour la plupart ils comprennent
rien à la chose militaire ce qu'ils
n'ont pas été dedans ça les salles aider
parce qu ils peuvent même pas envisager
l'idée de de faire ce qu'on a fait même
sans revenir blessé c'est pas
compréhensible pour eux d'aller là bas
du coup voilà bien être avec des gens
qui l'ont fait qui sont passés par là
c'est ça qui fait que c'est enrichissant
laisse penser que cette aventure elle
est belle c'est parce que c'est avant
tout une aventure humaine vous
mais maintenant le combat
[Applaudissements]
ce corps il faut l'accepter il ya une
acceptation à faire avec ce
nouveau corps ce corps meurtri qu'on
peut avoir du mal effectivement à
montrer même à soi-même un mois au début
j'avais du mal ne serait ce que pour la
douche
allez sur les cicatrices m
c'était difficile quoi donc l'ol exposés
aux autres c'est encore pire
un moment en fait on aura toujours en
affaires entre nous c'est eux aoued sa
cicatrice c'est tout ah ouais ça vous
sert à la tienne allait bien on
ce conte par quoi on regarde nos
cicatrices pas le tiennent a bien bossé
les meufs et un zigzag c'est la lamal
prise
[Applaudissements]
il ya pas de malaise
le commandant valérie fait partie de la
cellule dead aux blessés de l'armée de
terre elle les prépare jusqu'à la
compétition
[Applaudissements]
on a vraiment des situations de blessés
graves sont en lien long parcours de
reconstruction en nombre pour de soi
n'est pas terminée pour certains
même s'ils sont stables et consolidé ils
sont passés par des épreuves difficiles
et le sport c'est extraordinaire parce
que ça véhicule les valeurs qui sont les
leurs et
et le dépassement de l'enlever sûr que
nous on voit qu'on voit tout mais qu'un
subissent au quotidien
parfois il leur est impossible de dire
ce qu'il s'est passé les mots ne
viennent pas
au retour d'une mission en centrafrique
gérald n'était plus le même
ce qui s'est passé pour moi pendant
l'une des missions m'a rattrapé j'ai du
mal à l'accepter ça m'a bouffé mais mes
nuits il suffisait d'un geste ou d'une
odeur d'un mot qui ont frappé ce moment
là et puis forcément
on n'ose pas en parler c'est comme si de
rien n'était
en fait il a été face à la mort d'autrui
et il a eu l angoisse de sa propre mort
en fait c'est ça aussi le l'état de
stress post traumatique c'est
c'est cette trouille qu'on a et le
souvenir de la mort qui revient sans
cesse de l'événement de l'événement
traumatique
savard qui qu'est ce que tu veux
partir de là
facile de parler en seront blessées que
à la maison parce qu on inquiète un peu
tout le monde aussi plus facile de
parler avec avec blessés que dire à son
épouse de ce que l'on fait ou ce qu'on a
vécu
les inquiète il ya un trou nous en fait
on se prend jamais la tête tu vois plus
à briller à la maison mais parfois en
brie
moi j'ai pas des poules j'ai pas
d'enfants mais le fait d'en parler avec
les copains rien que ça déjà ça m'a
beaucoup aidé mais encore une fois sans
qu'il me sens qu'il me dise battu
devrait faire ci ou tu devrais faire ça
fun et si on ne demande pas
nécessairement avoir des conseils on va
là on veut juste une oreille en fête ses
100 ans sans jugement
et ce sentiment est partagé bien au-delà
de nos frontières
[Musique]
c'est une idée américaine pour aider
leurs héros à se reconstruire depuis les
attentats du 11 septembre les marines
ont créé une compétition pour les
blessés de guerre
cette année six nations sont invités à
concourir c'est comme une grande
thérapie de groupe en californie
[Musique]
les soldats français eux n'avait jamais
foulé le sol américain
pour se mettre dans le bain c'est sur la
plage privée des marines que les héros
sont accueillis loin très loin des
ambiances de garnison française
[Musique]
le lendemain matin les athlètes sont
déjà en piste
[Musique]
lionel a choisi de s'aligner sur
l'épreuve reine le 100 m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien
[Musique]
une course gagné haut la main et une
médaille d'or pour le clan français
tel qu on
line de plus
la même chose pour orléans
je me trouvais que je sers encore à
quelque chose
quand on est blessé c'est pas facile on
souvent isolés tout seul même s'il ya
des amis m'a pris la route le wagon
passe chacun fait ses missions la
famille spécialisée et fo se retrouve
tout seul et en
je me ferais je vois quelque chose les
gens qui valaient quelque chose
c'est parfait
mais là je savoure je pense à tout le
monde à ma femme ma fille c'est celle
pas celle que je suis au colosse une
femme formidable qui soutient et ma
petite fille
j'ai cherché les bains
mais lionel n'est pas au bout de ses
émotions et de ses efforts c'est
officiel vient lui annoncer une mauvaise
nouvelle
sa course est annulée les résultats ne
sont pas validés
[Musique]
pendant ce temps là sur le 1500 m gerald
de fait lui aussi sa course en tête
ah oui
au dernier moment il laisse son
coéquipier pierre lui passer devant et
puis je fais un cadeau
sa médaille d'or
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien engueuler dans le dernier tour
machine c'est je crois que je crois que
tu viens
tu crois toilettes il est de 10 mètres
derrière tu crois quoi la médaille d'or
et moi je voulais qu'il aura absolument
c'est bien juger grande classe
un mois après je veux voir d'un
spectateur parce que ça fait déjà un
petit moment que je peux plus courir non
ça fait plaisir ils ont tous
ils ont tous mis pied dedans là ils ont
pensé ok beaucoup à eux à l'image de
gégé qui a laissé la première place à un
pierre sur le 1500 j'ai encore une fois
le jury terme les félicitations parce
que c'est un monsieur d'heure fait ça
mais
parler c'est beau c'est un bel exemple
[Applaudissements]
je recule même couloir le même réglages
un peu superstitieux
je suis fou tu gagnes relations ont dû
tourner sa confiance et c'est la
blessure mais voilà on a fini par se
jeter médaillée d'or située à recycler
mais ils sont belges
pour l'équipe pour tout le monde pour
tous les blessés à part que jean que
cela c'est tous les blessés par nos
camarades qui sont m'essayer que son
parti
est au bout de leurs efforts
43 médailles pour l'équipe de france
c'est aussi une libération pour moi de
les voir comme ça dans des moments de
vie du jour la plupart du temps les mois
dans les souffrances mais dans des
questionnements donc la loi dans les
moments heureux c'est personnellement
très agréable
[Applaudissements]
chez pierre gourlain sacré plaisir
l'entrée axa ma fille à papa était mon
héros je suis
ça va
j'ai un peu court la guerre à ses héros
le sport aussi guillaume lionel et les
autres sont allés au bout de ce rêve que
leur a offert l'amérique ils ont livré
une autre bataille entre leurs blessures
et contre eux mêmes